Regarding Burberry, I saw on your website that there are different a couple different kinds of
Burberry. What's the best type of Burberry to take?
Okay, so for years and years and years the only type of Burberry was Burberry hydrochlorine, I think it was called
95% of the products the Burberry products of the market will contain that
about two years ago it was discovered that Burberry dihydro, what is it called? Burberry,
dihydro burberry, I think it's called DHB is literally in all the studies five times more bio
available, meaning that you could absorb it and it works five times better than the Burberry day to
sell. So we started carrying that as a private label, there's only a couple of companies that
you could get in front. We started carrying it as a private label as Burberry clear throw, we still
have the Burberry clear which is an old Burberry, but we switched all our patients to the Burberry clear
throw because, okay, so if you're taking three 500 milligram capsules of the old Burberry,
which again 95% of the Burberry in other markets that are old Burberry, it's still very good for you,
but if you took five, you took three, the same equivalent dosage of the Burberry throw,
it would literally have five times more benefit, or you could literally, if you only wanted that
smaller dose you could take less of it. So it is the same price, that's the weird thing. So
so it's the the Burberry clear throw is the product that we would recommend.